all of the writers that you interviewed
it seemed were older in age and I know
that Hollywood as places such an
emphasis on youth and a number of the
writers in the book talked about ageism
we're surprised Peter Casey who's 50 and
you know wings and Frasier he co-created
their show it said I couldn't get a show
on now 9050 would you hear somebody with
those credits saying you couldn't get a
show on that's pretty startling we enjoy
speaking to people that are just have
more experience well there there there
there is a little bit of Mythology
around this yes they want younger
writers but they will never let someone
in their mid-twenties run a show I'd say
the the age of people running shows now
it goes anywhere from like 35 up to 55
but there's also a mythology about we
interviewed Ed Decker the film wrote you
know there's something about Mary and he
was he was talking a lot about
demographics and saying that there there
are four boxes and you've got preteens
teens young adults and adults and the
you always want to go after as many
boxes as you can he gave an example he
said Shrek he sucks up movies for them
he said that was a perfect movie because
it hit everybody people have this idea
that young people spend the most money
and so that's the market you always want
to go after which certainly doesn't seem
to make as much sense to me in Hollywood
no income but there's this idea that
young people watch more they go out to
movies more they watch TV more so if
you're not going after that market then
you know a love story with two people in
their 50s is not going to sell and have
the same freshness as two people that
are coming of age or in their
20s yeah it's amazing to me and that's
not a comedy although it does have
wonderfully comedic moments and it's
amazing to me that Hitchcock is with
Helen Mirren and Anthony Hopkins is
doing as well as it is because there's
really no Scarlett Johansson's in it but
it's a relatively small part and and
Jessica Biel's in it it's also a small
part being looked at almost as a
documentary but it's a great I thought
it was wonderful it's a great romance
between a husband and a wife and really
how she did help form his career and
actually was his boss at one time when
they were first together and I think
it's great and I I wish you know and
there was a period of time in the
hollywood where most of the stars most
of the people working had experienced
and were i mean if you think about the
great stars of the 40s and 50s and even
the 30s they were not kids and but just
to go back to the writing thing I don't
believe staffs are full of people in
their early 20s takes about five years
to break in I have a student who's 26
she's on her first show she's certainly
not running it the two guys who were the
show runners are in their late 40s early
fifties and they've had a few bombs and
a few successes so I don't and the
answer to why I think that sometimes
they've the network's think that young
people have their finger on a pulse that
yeah but they don't have the experience
or the craft so it's the only business I
know of where like if you were going to
if you were up for murder and you were
going to a lawyer who would you go to
the guy who have been practicing
criminal law for years and years and
years and knew everybody in the industry
or would you go to some guy just out of
Law School
I don't think you would so it's kind of
a weird dynamic and it makes no logical
sense but it's what using that analogy
that analogy would be yeah but we got
this hot new lawyer with incredible new
vision and new techniques there's great
ways to get people that these old
codgers don't yet so yeah that's the way
they're selling it I haven't seen well
most of the showrunners I know of drama
and comedy are older I mean you know
they're not kids so and and the people
who are making decisions at the networks
and at the real decision-makers the
people who can greenlight things are
still older people they're not they'll
never let a 25 year old decide how to
run a network I mean I just don't think
that's ever gonna happen the business
side is always gonna be you know like
banker age you know so knowing that
people may have an expiration date as
cold as that sounds
mm-hmm how should someone plan around
that who's still very talented what else
can they envision for themselves if they
feel like you know what I'm going to be
booted out of the Hollywood system well
I can tell you what I know I wish it
were that clean that you knew where you
were gonna be booted out it's usually a
slow it's kind of like thing they put
leeches on you and bleed you out slowly
you know most of the people I know I
know
like they either change careers so that
my form of writing partner is an
associate director and she's made a very
good career for herself she stopped
writing about ten years ago I mean she's
still writing but she's not writing
television and she's on Big Bang and
before that she was on Will & Grace she
just pilot she's always working and then
the other thing that I've noticed is
that writers after certain age they
become novelists or they become
playwrights so they become you just do
other kinds of writing you know and then
ironically some of them end up selling
their novels to the very system that
done with them you know I think I think
the rule is there are no rules I don't
think it's like banking or law or
medicine I think for every rule I mean
Peters writing a script with an old
friend right now which I think even
though it'll be a tough sell I think it
will get made and I and and that's kind
of ironic because I mean they're old
farts um you know you want the double
the diet are lotta legumes you eat those
right
you